[MUSIC PLAYING]
DALE LEWIS: We are
British Telecoms.
We are one of the largest UK
network and telecommunications
providers.
We also operate globally
across 180 different countries.
And we work specifically
in BT digital.
And really, we are
focused on taking BT
from being a telco
into a techco.
So it really means
transforming core structures
and technologies, including
the drive to cloud adoption.
DANIEL RANDELL:
Our key goals are
to align with moving
away from our legacy
tightly-coupled architecture
with our on-premise data
warehouses and towards a
loosely-coupled managed data
mesh architecture that will
enable new and exciting value
from our data.
RYAN FLYNN: Each week, we
have around 30 requests
that have to be provisioned.
And it would take an engineer
around three hours to do.
We knew that with the
[INAUDIBLE] adoption GCP about
to begin in the business, we had
to have a solution that can not
only react to the potential
100 project requests,
but also react to
this demand to build
a project as soon as possible.
For a team of only
four engineers,
this is a huge
undertaking that we
had to do within three months.
DALE LEWIS: Our DevOps
philosophy really
is that it's a must have.
It's a core belief.
It's something we
know we have to do.
We have to be able
to move faster.
to change quickly.
To do that safely, we
need to use DevOps.
We need to really understand it.
We need to build,
measure, learn.
And I'm not just saying that.
We need to physically look at
the metrics we're producing,
get that continuous
feedback loop.
And DevOps is at the core of
everything we do within BT.
DANIEL RANDELL: We reached out
to collaborate with a Google
Cloud team of
[INAUDIBLE] and engineers
to ask them if some of the
problems that we faced,
it had been had elsewhere.
We were put into contact with an
engineer, who helped to give us
a jump start solution.
And with that, we
saw the ability
to see what was possible and
how we could quickly redevelop
and expand that into the
solution it is today.
RYAN FLYNN: It was interesting
to see the true limits
of our automation.
In 24 hours, we managed to
create 1,000 projects using
automation in order to handle
the surge requests that
came as a result of
GCP adoption in BT.
DALE LEWIS: We'd
like to say thank
you to Google first for the
technology and the work we
get to do.
I'd like to say a big
thank you to my squad.
You've met Dan and Ryan here.
But we also have
another engineer
who's been supporting
us and a new joiner who
recently joined the team to--
we're not doing
something small here.
We're migrating the largest
customer database in the UK.
And we've got so
much value to find.
And BT has tens of thousands
of analysts and data
scientists ready to go.
And this automation
is what's going
to give us the
speed and efficiency
to enable them to get
a hold of our data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]